[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista en Francia
24 hoy desde el foro económico mundial
estamos con la ministra de minas y
energía de Colombia Irene Vélez Torres
ministra Muchas gracias por atendernos y
le pregunto primero Colombia quiere
hacer pionera en la región casi en
transición hacia energías más limpias
como lo van a lograr nosotros tenemos la
necesidad de hacer una transición
energética justa Y esa necesidad parte
de la convicción fundamental de que se
va a desvalorizar el mercado de los
hidrocarburos y ya se está
desvalorizando el mercado del Carbón a
pesar de que este contexto particular de
la guerra entre Ucrania y Rusia elevó
los precios sabemos que las inversiones
por ejemplo están decayendo de manera
acelerada en el mercado del Carbón
entonces frente a ese contexto y nuestra
dependencia económica la transición
energética justa en Colombia pasa por
por supuesto la penetración de las
renovables pero también por generar un
nuevo modelo económico del extractivismo
al modelo productivo Entonces en ese
sentido nuestra estrategia tiene varios
niveles tiene un nivel que pasa por
acelerar las energías renovables tenemos
un enorme potencial en la costa Caribe
fundamentalmente en términos de
generación solar y eólica ahí tenemos
desafíos fundamentalmente sociales que
tenemos que superar porque aunque hay
unos proyectos que ya están en
construcción también ha habido una
conflictividad social muy grande que nos
ha logrado superarse y que por lo cual
ha también varios de estos
proyectos Entonces el enfoque que
tenemos ahí es un enfoque que tiene que
ser no solo técnico sino también Social
para asegurar que con las comunidades
llegamos a un acuerdo para que estos
proyectos que son relevantes para la
transición energética sean también
relevantes para la justicia social en la
guajira fundamentalmente
es es entonces una ruta de la
penetración de las renovables pero otra
es también El reemplazo del modelo
económico y en eso necesitamos un modelo
productivo basado por supuesto en la
agricultura en el turismo muy importante
en la bioeconomía en la naturaleza de
manera que haya esquemas de conservación
que generen también recursos y que las
energías renovables sean también una
fuente económica adicional ministra Cómo
está la relación hoy en día con la
industria petrolera una reforma
tributaria que incrementó algunos de los
impuestos para ellos también está todo
este tema de los contratos que de los
contratos de exploración Cómo está la
relación qué piensa por ejemplo una
empresa productora que hoy está
explotando y que no vaya a poder seguir
explorando
las relaciones Bueno también porque la
industria sabe que hay un declive en las
inversiones En el sector de
hidrocarburos en la Cope 26 que se
realizó en Glasgow hubo unos países del
g20 que acordaron que iban
progresivamente a reducir sus
inversiones por fuera del país o versis
en hidrocarburos y en carbono eso nos
afecta porque la medida en que hay menos
inversiones por supuesto la industria va
a ir recogiéndose entonces frente a eso
que es una realidad global no es algo
que decidamos como gobierno sino que es
un contexto económico global lo más
inteligente que podemos hacer es ajustar
nuestras propias medidas nacionales y
por eso para nosotros va a ser muy
relevante el tema de recobro mejorado
que es básicamente que en los procesos
de explotación de hidrocarburos
fundamentalmente de petróleo actualmente
tenemos podamos incrementar la
productividad a través de la tecnología
eso es muy importante se hace muy poco
en Colombia se hace mucho más en otros
países eso tiene que ver con el Trader
off de esa tecnología en los precios
internacionales pero con los precios
actuales eso se puede por otro lado que
seamos eficientes en la exploración o
sea tenemos muchas áreas tenemos en el
país 380 áreas que tienen en este
momento contratos activos entonces lo
que queremos es que en esas áreas haya
una exploración que sea efectiva que sea
eficiente que se haga en los tiempos en
que corresponden nos pasa mucho que la
exploración tiene un periodo máximo de
seis años pero también tiene una
posibilidad de extenderse un poco más y
se explora en un ritmo demasiado lento
de manera que se toma todo el periodo y
al final entonces lo que creemos es que
haciendo una gestión mejor de la
exploración podemos acelerar también la
explotación de manera que se robustezca
el sector de hidrocarburos no a través
de nuevas áreas sino a través de las
áreas existentes con una utilización de
la tecnología y de una gestión eficiente
de la exploración ministra desde hace
varios años Colombia tiene algunos
proyectos con países vecinos Como por
ejemplo tiene pendiente una
interconexión eléctrica con Panamá
también hay algunos proyectos de
geotermia en la frontera con Ecuador y
con Venezuela se había hablado de
inclusive llegar a ser una exploración
conjunta de la faja del Orinoco en que
se ha avanzado en todos esos proyectos
bueno Comencemos con la frontera con
Venezuela nosotros los dos países están
en un proceso muy interesante que por
supuesto es recuperar las relaciones
diplomáticas como parte de esa
recuperación estamos haciendo un
inventario de cuáles son esos proyectos
energéticos que compartíamos entre los
dos países y tú tienes razón tenemos un
proyecto de gasoducto que teníamos entre
los dos países y Tenemos también unas
redes eléctricas entre ambos países
entonces lo que sigue en la recuperación
de esa relación diplomática es hacer
unas evaluaciones técnicas del estado de
esa infraestructura Porque en la medida
en que no se ha utilizado en los últimos
años se ha descuidado también lo primero
es saber cuál es el estado para de la
misma manera poder proceder a conocer
cómo es que tenemos que mejorar y
hacerlo habilitarlo para que sea
funcional tenemos unas redes una una red
de interconexión con el Ecuador
una red eléctrica ahí esa red es muy
importante y el ecuador Tuvimos una
reunión con el ministro de energía del
Ecuador en diciembre del año pasado y en
esa reunión hubo una disponibilidad para
que habláramos sobre la posibilidad de
construir otra red adicional eso es algo
que vamos a planearlo en el marco de la
olade y lo que nos importa ahí es un
poco entenderlo desde la perspectiva
demanda o sea cuál es la energía que se
demanda entre ambos países y en ese
flujo cómo puede ser rentable de alguna
manera también construir esta esta red
ampliada digamos expansión de la red de
interconexión y finalmente Panamá Panamá
es un proyecto que ambos países tienen
hace mucho tiempo hay unos acuerdos de
entendimiento entre ambos gobiernos sin
embargo esa iniciativa ha estado
básicamente frenada hubo un primer
intento de revivirla en 2021
y nosotros tuvimos en el marco de la
olade el 16 de diciembre de 2022 una
reunión con el ministro de Panamá
precisamente para recuperar y acelerar
la posibilidad de esa interconexión
frente a eso tenemos un plan de trabajo
muy claro tenemos una primera reunión
técnica de alto nivel que nos interesa
mucho que se involucren tanto las
entidades vibratorias como las entidades
de planificación Y por supuesto los
ministros pero digamos que sea una cosa
más de sector y no solamente de
ministerios porque se requiere una
armonización regulatoria pero también se
requiere establecer Cuáles son las
ofertas y las demandas posibles la
importancia de la interconexión en
América Latina es total porque
permitiría aprovechar de mejor manera
las energías renovables que se están
acelerando en la región que las
renovables del Desierto de atacama en
Chile puedan penetrar y ayudar a
descarbonizar la matriz eléctrica de
toda la región que la energía renovable
que nosotros podamos producir en el
Caribe colombiano pueda ayudar a
descarbonizar toda la región e incluso
poder impactar positivamente al norte
del continente Entonces es una
importancia política y energética muy
grande contribuye a la descarbonización
el cambio climático y requiere voluntad
política que yo creo que en América
Latina estamos en un momento único
pensarnos nuevamente la integración
latinoamericana y como parte de esa
integración la integración eléctrica
pero no solo eléctrica y ahí yo creo que
el punto tuyo es muy clave y es También
estamos hablando de otros energéticos en
este momento la crisis que tenemos de
abastecimiento en el sur del país de
nariño y de cauca nos pone de manifiesto
la importancia que tendría tener una
interconexión en gas por ejemplo estamos
haciendo una logística increíble sacando
buques con petróleo y con gas desde
Barranquilla desde Cartagena pasando por
el canal de Panamá llegando hasta tumaco
intentando pasarlos ahí otra maniobra
increíble sacando de mocoa pasando por
Ecuador Todo esto que además hace muy
costoso por el transporte está este
abastecimiento de hidrocarburos podría
mejorarse si tuviéramos esa
interconexión en otros energéticos no la
tenemos pero es uno de los desafíos que
estamos Y que todos los países de la
región estamos muy claros en la
importancia de poderlos afrontar juntos
la hora que se reabre en fronteras Antes
había una relación muy dinámica en la
frontera sobre todo lo que tiene que ver
con combustibles Cómo va esto de ahora
en adelante todavía no Hemos llegado a
ese punto
porque Esto va por pasos Entonces lo más
importante era la relación diplomática
que se restableciera eso ya se logró por
otro lado la el tránsito de las personas
Eso era absolutamente crucial que
pudiéramos que los venezolanos que
estuvieran en el país pudieran regresar
si así lo veían conveniente hay también
un restablecimiento de el transporte de
mercancías eso también ya está en
proceso y nosotros estamos en el momento
en el que tenemos que pasar a hacer una
revisión técnica de las infraestructuras
existentes Ya hicimos inventario de qué
es lo que hay en términos de proyectos
que había antes de el cierre de esas
relaciones diplomáticas y lo que sigue
es esa evaluación técnica una vez
sepamos de la evaluación técnica una vez
tengamos resultados en ese sentido
sabremos Cuáles son las necesidades y
eso pero la verdad es que pues tantos
años sin tener relaciones apenas estamos
recuperando los diálogos con decirte que
yo todavía no he hablado con el ministro
de petróleo de El Venezuela y yo creo
que eso tiene que pasar antes que
cualquier cosa entonces pues vamos bien
pero no nos estamos acelerando en un
proceso que tiene que hacerse con mucha
certezas Muchas gracias ministra por
estar en France 24 Muchas gracias a ti
por la invitación Daniela a ustedes
también gracias por su sintonía esta
entrevista la pueden consultar en France
24.com